So here we're going to work
through this simple example again,
using our 4s and 9s.
We're going to assume that we have
some feature that we're measuring, x.
It's typically a vector, but
I'm going to show it here as a scalar.
So x goes from small x,
so little x, to big x.
All right?
It's changing, changing values.
Clearly, all the way to the left,
I've got more 4s, and
all the way to the right, I've got
more 9s at the best decision boundary.
Okay?
And that's what's indicated in red here.
At that boundary,
if I call it a four, or
I call it a nine,
it should cost me on average the same.
Because in fact, if,
if calling it a four would
be less risk than calling a nine, I'm
going to move that boundary this way.
And if cost, calling it a nine is
better than calling in a four,
I'm going to move the boundary that way.
So at the best possible boundary,
the expected loss is the same
regardless of which label I announce.
All right, so if we picked label four,
okay, at that boundary.
Okay, then the expected loss is what?
Well, it's just, what is the probability
that it's really a nine,
and that I call it a four,
the cost of calling it a four?
And what's the probability
that it's really a four, and
the loss of calling it a four?
Well if you remember, remember we
assumed that the loss of x to x is zero,
that is, there's no cost
of calling a four a four.
Well that means that this
just reduces down to,
well, if I'm at this location, x, what's
the probability it's really a nine?
And the cost of calling the nine a four?
That's the expected loss of
saying four at that location.
Likewise, what's the expected loss,
if I say nine at that location?
Well, symmetrically,
it's just what is the probability
that it actually was a four?
And what's the loss of
calling a four a nine?
Okay, so those are the two different
value, the losses, that I want.
Now, remember we said before at the best
decision boundary either labeling a four
or labeling a nine, the cost,
the expected cost would be the same.
So the best decision boundary is where,
is the x such
that the probability that
the class is really a nine times
the cost of calling a nine a four,
will be equal to
the probability that it's really a four
times the loss of calling a four a nine.
When I set those two values equal,
that's the x that I want for
my decision boundary.
What that means is,
if I'm going to classify a new point,
I'm just going to look at these values,
right?
At some new point x.
What's the probability that it's really
a four times the probability that I call
a four a nine?
If that's greater than
the probability that it's a nine
times the loss of calling a nine a four,
if that's true,
I'm going to call this thing a four,
otherwise, I'm going to call it a nine.